chuckle what is the biggest turnaround
on stance / opinion you've ever made now
this is one of those questions that I
sat there and thought about it for a
while and then I realized that the
answer was sitting right in front of my
face
literally sitting right in front of my
face and that is this mm-hmm it's the
podcast the book the social media all of
it because I've talked about this before
I was raised in the SEAL Teams to be the
quiet professional and as a matter of
fact one of my one of my favorite seals
when I was a young young guy at team one
this guy was just a just a total badass
frogman and learned I learned a ton from
him and he was actually you know some
people say oh that guy's good at
everything
mmm this guy was actually awesome at
everything like everything that there
was to do at shooting at fighting at
climbing at tactics everything that he
did he was awesome at and he was super
super hardcore just tough and in fact
one of the stories about him is that
when he joined the Navy and he had to
come to boot camp I guess in San Diego
he paddled a kayak from where he lived
to get into San Diego and he was 17
years old by the way he was just a 17
year old kid joined the Navy when he was
17 and then I had no way of getting here
so go take a kayak put it in the water
and paddle to San Diego that seems to be
the the smart way to do things and so
back in the day he had a hat and he had
this hat and this is before you see seal
memorabilia everywhere you just see it
yeah all over the place he had this hat
with just a trident on it nothing else
just to try it in and then under the
Trident it just said the words the
silent option and I always thought to
myself yes that is it right there that's
us right the silent option no fanfare
known
newse no parade no fame or fortune or
glory of any kind no none of that
the silent option that's it and pretty
much everybody that I looked up to in
the SEAL Teams had that kind of attitude
and there's something that is obviously
so pure about that that attitude so
selfless that none of what you did as a
seal was ever for any kind of
recognition ever and that to me was sort
of the code now there were people that
stepped out from that code and while it
certainly wasn't encouraged it wasn't
really ridiculed either either I mean
people people did it people wrote books
and it was it wasn't looked that down
upon at the time unless you were a bad
team guy mmm if you were a bad seal or
if you're a guy that had a bad
reputation you would be crushed in the
SEAL Teams
amongst the team guys in the community
now civilians they don't know the
difference right I mean two civilians
how can they tell they just a seal as a
seal as a seal so they're good with it
but in the teams if you had a bad
reputation your reputation would get
even worse if you if you broke the code
so when I retired I had zero intention
of of going public right of becoming
this and and then when I started working
with civilian companies and Lafe and I
formed a company echelon front and we
realized pretty quickly that there's a
big need for people to learn what we had
to teach and really quickly the demand
for us to write this down and be able to
give it to people grew and it was really
obvious to us so when that started when
we when that started and we started
wrote it down and then that started to
transform this idea of what we had
written down started transforming into
becoming a book like a legitimate book I
got
really nervous and scared and kind of
almost sick right I was definitely
definitely very weary about it and I
think I did some little self-sabotage
along the way just a little bit ear
there you know I just do well I don't
know you're probably not gonna be you
know we I think I did some of that stuff
I'd have to I'd have to think about in
fact I know I did some of it because
it's kind of an all-or-nothing
proposition right you're either do it or
you don't do it and I guess you could
try and use like a pseudonym but then
that doesn't really that's not me right
I'm not gonna even I'm not gonna make up
a person how do you write and not be me
right so that wasn't really an option
and and furthermore I knew that that
doesn't really last either I mean the
pseudonyms eventually people figure out
who they are and so that's the way it
works and I think the thing that finally
made me say okay I'm gonna do this is
that I as I decided like okay I'm gonna
do this I just kind of knew I wasn't
gonna be anything else other than one I
was right I'm not gonna try and put on
some persona or be something that or not
I'm just gonna be me and I've got you
know that that's what I'm gonna do and
so that's what I did you know the the me
that is here is just me there's no
nothing special that's just who I am and
that's all I did was basically expose
what I am to you know people in the
public now the thing is now that I
actually am out there a little bit and
people can kind of see me in the world
right there's definitely some things
that I don't like about it or I should
say I don't like there's some challenges
right there's some challenges there for
instance you're being watched all the
time you're being followed and being
you're being judged
and those things right there are
coincidentally the exact same kind of
challenges you face when you're in a
leadership position that I face when I
was leadership position oh people are
watching me oh people are judging me I'm
used to that that's what it was like
when I was in the SEAL Teams and just
like when I was in the SEAL Teams I
always tried to stay true to what I
believed in and what I believed was
right and not to say I never made
mistakes I obviously did but I always
gave it my all to do the best job I
could do and to take care of my guys my
brothers and my friends that's what I
always tried to do and really that's all
I'm still trying to do it's just to give
something back to pass on some of the
things some of the little things that I
learned along the way and really when I
get the feedback from from my SEAL
teammates from guys that are still
active duty in the SEAL Teams from
soldiers and Marines that are retired or
guys that are still on active duty or
guys that transition in the civilian
world all those guys guys from the front
lines that are on the front lines are
right now and then guys that are law
enforcement and firefighters and when
all those that whole crew that whole
group of people send me some kind of
thanks it's awesome and in addition to
them I don't know if this is surprising
or not but I hear from just everyday
normal people to civilians right
businessmen laborers entrepreneurs
builders mechanics plumbers electricians
software engineers doctors men and women
girls and boys young and all just every
imaginable size shape color of person
from every
walk of life and I hear from them and
when I hear from them and I see that
they're getting something out of this
that makes those little challenges of
judgment and and scrutiny
it makes all those worthwhile to me
because once again I feel like I'm part
of something that's bigger than me
bigger than myself something more
powerful than I could ever be by myself
something stronger than I could ever be
alone and for me to be doing what I can
do to to help that and to have that to
have trying to help be both the task and
the reward it's a reward to help people
that to me has made it worthwhile yeah I
could see that will give the silent
professional mm-hmm the quiet
professional yeah and the silent option
yeah two different variations on the
same theme is that because if that
wasn't there you'd I would imagine you'd
get a bunch of hey look at me I was such
a I was such a badass and all these
stories and you know because I think
that like what what you and life have
and even this podcast and stuff sure
there's like references tour but it's
not about like who let me spin all the
cool tales that the war that I went
through and stuff like that it's it's
more about like the actual principles of
leadership and what give effective you
know even though I know the general
public would probably want to hear every
last cool
story and how you saved this person or
you know killed all these baguette or
whatever you know everyone want to hear
that
but that's not what it's about that's
not like what you're going public with
you know it's more about like okay this
valuable stuff that it's that easy tried
tested in basically the harshest of
conditions you know that work everywhere
and like that's the valuable part I
don't even know if that's even like
seeking glory in any way well again I've
said this before you can say that you're
not trying to seek glory but then when
you write a 300-page book about yourself
you know what I mean and then you have a
podcast about yourself it's like it just
is what it is like there's no that that
has a level of of self-centeredness that
you can't I mean you can't avoid I can't
deny right I can't deny like actually no
the podcast is it's it's a podcast and I
talk on it for two hours right that's
that's me talking right yeah so there is
it there is a level of that that you
can't escape from and I talked about
this before but that book the electric
kool-aid acid test which I don't maybe
I'll do but it's it's about the hippies
and the drug revolution well this one
part of it where this guy is listening
there he's up in haight-ashbury in San
Francisco and he goes on this tangent
about how what they're saying is me me
me me look at me and when I read that
for the first time I'll say I never want
to be that person that's saying that
yeah and that's that but again the
dichotomy here is I have a podcast I
have a book and and the book is me and
the podcast me and so it's unavoidable
to have a podcast that you talk on and
not have it somehow be about you it just
doesn't happen
yeah so that's a real challenge and I do
my best to mitigate that but you can't
stop it it is factually a podcast that
I'm in it is factually a book that I
wrote
you know it's a book that factually Lafe
wrote so that's just what it is and so
you can't take those away the only thing
that mitigates that feeling from me is
again what I just said is when you got
when I got soldiers Marine when I got
seal teammates of mine that are fired up
and they're there they're saying hey
that was awesome thanks for that one
this this was great
I've never knew that or whatever they're
gonna say right and then on top of that
you know you get civilians that are
saying hey I stopped using drugs because
of your podcast that is awesome
yeah I don't like drugs and so when
somebody tells me that they stop using
drugs because of the podcast that that
makes me feel very gratified when
somebody calls me up I just had it or
somebody uh on Twitter just said of guys
like 53 years old and he said hey I've
lost X amount of pounds forty something
pounds and he said I just did the first
legit pull-up of my life 53 years old 53
years old just did the first legitimate
pull-up of his life he's like thank you
that is worth the the the daggers that
stick me in my brain because I know I
sold out and I sold out but that's what
it is is is that is it just mean do you
get like scrutiny from people at all for
quote-unquote selling out or is it in
order
you think yeah but my bros and the teams
are there right that's what I would
think and it is because the whole
dynamic I mean yeah I mean you gotta be
like Jaco podcast it's called jackal
podcast it's about me you kind of have
to do that yeah I mean there's there's a
small element of that that you have to
include about yourself
there are credibility reasons all this
stuff but then aside from that it's it's
valuable stuff it's not glory-seeking
stuff at all this is like stuff that's
helpful you know help like if you the
stuff that you can benefit from from
this podcast from the book if your
neighbor if the people in your
neighborhood all incorporated these
principles into their life it'd be a
better neighborhood so what
not like you know I'm just this you look
at me I'm a war hero you know it's not
that no no so it makes it worth it I
mean I mean I dig it though that like
tradition if let's just say if there is
like a person who is like a you know
like a I do what you're doing but you
shouldn't do that that's the code that's
a tradition that you know the code you
sold out I would understand that look I
think that's just like you're not
looking at the big picture yeah yeah no
it definitely was when I hear back from
we're not here good like I said when I
hear from actor do Miller when I hear
from my steel Bros that are that are
telling me this is awesome that that's
that makes it worthwhile to me and
that's sort of why I keep doing it that
and again these civilian folks that are
out there that are that are just
changing their lives and and again I
whenever they say all thank you I say I
didn't do anything you did it that guy
that did his first pull up his first
legit pull up in 53 years of life you
know what that's awesome I didn't do
that pull up he did he had to put all
the work and all he did was change his
attitude and get in the game and now
he's you know having a much better
situation in his life because your life
is better if you go from zero pubs to
one your life just got better your life
just got a lot better as a matter of
fact yeah so yeah but but it was
interesting as I sat here and talked
about the coin I thought about the
question the biggest turnaround I've
been really pretty steady in my beliefs
for a long time I mean about this you
mean no just in general just like in
general if you if you were to interview
me now and you interviewed me ten years
ago they because I was probably a little
bit dumber ten years ago as dumb dumber
six months ago but my broad beliefs
would be somewhat similar right yeah and
it was I was thinking okay what's the
biggest turnaround and then I realized
oh yeah
obviously this is a huge turnaround for
me and and there were guys that you know
wind guys in the SEAL Teams found out
that hangar book coming out yeah there
was definitely some guys that were like
dude what are you doing and I was you
know and then they'd read it and say hey
man you know credit it's cool all good
you know and that's the way it is let's
say you were to not rewind life but
you're
take the jakka from before before Ramadi
how about that mmm Jacques from and then
the idea was introduced hey like what do
you like what did you feel about that
like if someone went and wrote a book
and it you know did a podcast or
something like what was your podcast
back then but generally generally
negative yeah that's that's why it's a
big turnaround right because if you told
me that years ago I'd be like you know
we're quiet professionals we don't do
that kind of thing
so here I am mr. quiet professional yeah
okay not so quiet still a professional
though trying to keep a professional
it's definitely trying to keep it
professional
it's good yeah is there you know how
like some you know people who change
their attitude on things all the time
sometimes get frowned upon this is just
in general for being like a flip-flopper
yeah like politics but isn't that kind
of good if your if your ideas about
things always are updated yeah it's okay
with me I don't want it I don't mind if
people change their opinion over time as
they is they bring on new knowledge but
there's a point where that becomes
ridiculous right yeah well yeah it kind
of depends on why they're changing their
mind that's true too so if it's like
with the introduction of new facts and
stuff like that and they're like okay I
didn't know that now you know it paints
a broader you know more accurate picture
so now I feel this way and we're
starting to feel this way about but
there's a there's a bias you know talk
about cognitive bias called
it's called I think it's called backfire
effect and it's the opposite so like new
factual information will come in and the
tendency is to be like it's to dig
deeper into your current belief oh for
sure in fact I can I can talk about that
I I've seen that happen before and what
I've seen that happen is people when
they the way that they first learned to
do something in the SEAL Teams is the
way they believe is correct right and
you have to beat it out of them like oh
as we learn new tactics like whenever
wherever some guy went to their first
training at a SEAL team wherever they
went and whoever taught them that's sort
of what they believed and anyone else
that comes in with a new idea
be all your man you don't know no that's
not the best way and so and I I figured
that out real quick when I was in
training when I was when I was running
training and I realized oh oh I got to
get over this barrier of you know this
guy learned it at this team or wherever
and or he learned it from this guy and
so he's got to have that in his head
that that's the only way to do things
cool it's got a just got a I wouldn't
aggressively attack it of course I'd say
oh yeah that's a great tactic what they
do yeah that this and you know what
we're about to show you actually mixes
in with a tactic good you might want to
you know it's something you could use
along with your tactic and then they
realize that the tactic we're teaching
is superior because we've evolved right
I had to involved we learned tactics new
tactics all the time the fundamental
principles didn't change but the
execution at a tactical level would
change because we got better updated
yeah well I took it's called war you
know we went to war and when soon as we
went to war we started figuring out some
of the stuff where that we had been
taught didn't really function the way we
it was literally like pre UFC martial
arts yeah yeah right you know pre UFC
martial arts if you learned that you
know if I touch your neck in this
particular manner you're gonna fall down
and nothing is gonna save you from that
and if you get taught that you might
believe it yeah and then somebody
punches you in the face or does a double
leg takedown on you in slams you into
the ground
yeah when you try and karate chop their
neck so it was the same thing in the
SEAL Teams we had tactics that had
evolved during a peacetime environment
in a in a bubble and so when the war
started we said oh okay we need to we
need to do an immediate check on all
these things yeah my friend was in from
out of town it's the past weekend we
watch the fights and the guys were in
this specific position you know standing
and kind of from the back there and he
and he asked he's like hey couldn't he
just like throw knees and give him like
the meanest charley horse right there
and then we're like it's not we don't
say it's not kind of sending or anything
but if you don't know you don't know
yeah it's like so we said no I mean yeah
you could but that wouldn't do anything
I mean I don't think you even feel that
you know how I put it was I say
charley horses are for when you're
cruising and you see your friend you're
like and you do it and it like hurts
them he's like oh you know but know when
you're in fighting like yet you don't
really feel a charley horse you don't
know that being said if somebody if
you're in a position somebody starts
dropping yeah twelve to six elbows onto
your thigh and they're big enough and
they're big and you're kind of stuck
there
you'll feel those you'll see a guy even
in the UFC you'll see a guy make
adjustments that move cuz he doesn't
want to get take you know twelve those
shots that's not gonna be fun yeah my
example was a leg kick so a leg kick is
essentially can be like a charley horse
you know like yeah give your friend a
charley really know the major exactly
right and that's the point
yeah the point is like what you would
think is a common Charlie Charlie horse
like with your friend or its whatever
like oh like a el borde you punch it or
even you need or whatever is different
than like to kind of turn the horse that
will be effective in yeah and but in a
fight in an MMA it takes even 99% of the
time with leg kicks it does take
multiple rounds worth of leg kicks
before you can actually affect the guy
it might slow the guy down a little bit
he's a little less apt to to be have
weight on that front leg or whatever but
then you know you see there's been
fights that have ended because third or
fourth round the guy's been kicked in
the leg forty seven times and is it's
just easy he breaks yeah yeah just again
just one of those things like yeah
there's much in the world that looks
like that either gee if you don't know
it seems like it'd be easy yeah and it's
not easy in jiu-jitsu is a classic or
MMA is a classic example that but
there's so many things I mean even a
normal sport you know baseball meal hey
how hard can be to hit that ball all
smooth sex yeah also is rock climbing
you know you look and say oh that money
just grabbed that thing right there
yeah no hold on yeah just hold on no
doesn't work that way yeah boy like you
know when they drop the voice oh my gosh
you couldn't even catch the balls right
in his hands
okay so Trey you you're a football now
of course they're trained I understand
but you you know that's
kind of part of the point you know them
being trained made it look like it's so
easy you seen it done on that time it in
what's interesting is when this
transfers over into the interpersonal
and the leadership realm and it's the
same exact thing where if you don't know
you don't know and you see people that
are you know younger leaders or they're
not very experienced and they'll be
making the same kind of rookie mistakes
or have the same kind of of opinion of
one we just tell them to do this oh
that's a very easy way to tell me you
can't tell them just don't think you
know you just tell them to do that
they're just not gonna listen to you
because they don't have respect for you
cuz you don't have a relationship you
haven't built anything up yet so you can
end up with the same thing in that
aspect of life as you do in a war
fighting aspect of life as you do in a
sports aspect of life it's all the same
yeah you've got to learn the skills you
got to practice the skills yeah even
like shooting a gun yeah Oh super easy
right yeah let's see somebody knockout
you know it's it's it it's a skill I
mean it's easier it's obviously easier
to kill someone with a gun than it is
with a knife or with your bare hands
it's an easier method but yeah you see
you know you see this all-time you see
little gunfights where people fight
shoot 20 25 rounds add another guy and
they don't hit them and they're only ten
feet away you know so shooting is easier
but it it still is a skill you need to
practice it's not just all that like put
like just firing it you know you know
like on movies I think I'll be like one
hand you know whatever boom boom boom
a real more accurate representation of
how he would go is like you know the
kind movies where the girl but they'd
totally do mean women a lot of the times
one thing the girl grabs the gun and
she's like and she shoots it and then
like it flies out of her hand
oh yeah that's probably pretty accurate
if you ever shot a gun well yeah if
someone's never shot a gun before yeah
the first time I ever took my wife to
arrange to teach her shooting and she
was kind of that way you know kind of
scared and intimidated and she was kind
of almost shaking a little bit and a
half an hour later I had her doing
quickdraws from the holster the gun down
targets I said yeah you're
right now oranges she says shut up and
reload my magazine okay cool we got this
you've seen those videos online I mean I
don't know how much time you spend
watching videos online but they're more
just for entertainment but of people
like shooting oh those are good I if I'm
gonna spend time watching videos I'm
watching to actually guys that are good
that have some knowledge to put out on
it stuffs you can learn so check
although you can learn from watching
somebody face with shotgun when they
shoot it wrong all right awesome